I think something that we are losing
right now and something I really care
about very much is the this this idea
that you have to be singular as an
artist you it can't be just you know Co
copying can be part of the game
obviously but and it should be at some
point but but you have to find the voice
that's that's proper to you and if today
in Europe or you know I go to film fund
with a or broadcaster with a project and
that's a that's a screenplay and I tell
them this is I'm going to do this and
chances are it's going to be a judged by
a commission and the commissions are
made of bureaucrats or pseudo
intellectuals disguising you know so I
don't know uh civil servants and they're
going to go for the average they always
go for the average so so in a way the
films that you're going to see uh
chances are and the European system but
America is different it's it's a
different hell but uh I'm not I mean we
might talk about it later but but in
Europe I'm just talking about what I
what I know it's always going to be the
the last singular possible I mean I know
because I when my first film it was the
terrible wall to make it happen so there
is an
Institutional uh reluctance to to to
anything that's singular that's why I
I'm so um
uh I'm I'm so impressed by painters
because they can really you know they
don't need stupid commissions uh they
can make their movies you know and and
my own Master billar just you know told
me that you have to make your movie you
know that's you whatever it takes take
your iPhone and um and it's strange that
the more people take their iPhones to
make their movies the more standardized
everything gets you know it's it's weird
that we have the diverse iversity of
point of views but people copy each
other like never before even in the
Western World Singularity is despised
because for many reasons why are people
put putting themselves in on Tik Tok to
to watch themselves and communicate what
they have to say is it democracy I don't
want to see your face I don't want to
see I'm not interested is it like the
expression of art this I mean
for me as a filmmaker obstacle course
are part of the are part of the of the
difficulty the struggle is with yourself
with the material Material World the
physical world that's always been part
of the human expression and now we're
it up sorry for my language with
the with but because we're in love with
technology we want to be give so much of
our power to the computer and zeros and
ones and it you know it's going to bring
us to Hell way before the climate change
screws us up I often or even what you
said earlier about oh you have to make
that movie even if it takes taking your
iPhone to make the movie but then when
many people are doing it it's not really
worth it anymore or it just it's very
it's not really good anymore so I often
wonder because my generation what a lot
of artists are doing is because the
struggle of you know financially but
also get getting represented getting
attention um is so hard and it's so gate
kept it's reliant on very old structures
so they take their phones and The Poets
they publish um their work online the
painters they film their process all of
these things so what we are doing our
generation of artists we go online a big
part of them and but because we do that
it often gets devalued by older
institutions and I mean there is a point
for what art what art is good
but we have I personally think we have
found an answer to this because we have
these means in technology where we
can cheer each other up or find
Solutions but then how how are we
supposed to do that like how are we
going to cheer them you know speaking as
what L you want to no I just wanted to
say something to this I mean I talk to
you know Studio people all the time like
Executives in Hollywood all they want to
do is please the youth there not there's
nothing I mean I don't they want to
Second gu the audience to the extent
that they want to bring it down to their
imagined audience so they take everybody
for idiots basically they're possibly
very idiotic themselves so they
definitely not keeping the gates for you
know old people they want to make films
for the imagined young people they don't
even
exist